تفرقت سنايت لاعمال المنزل بعد ان فصلت من
عملها في مصنع للنسيج كان بابا رزقه
الوحيد تامل سنه الا يدوم هذا الوضع طويلا
خصوصا ان عملها ساهم في انتشارها واطفالها
من براثنر
عن خدماتي واخبروني انهم سيتصلون به اذا
استئناف الاعمال امنوا ان لا يدوم هذا
الوضع طويلا فانا اعيل طفلين وستكون
معيشتنا صعبه دون مصدر
فقدت حتى الان الفا عامله وظائفهن في
مصانع النسيج والسبب فقدانها امتياز اقوى
الذي كان يمنحها حق الوصول الى الاسواق
الامريكيه دون رسوم جمركيه وهو ما شجع
المصانع على الاستثمار في اثيوبيا قبل ان
تلغي واشنطن مؤخرا الامتيازه بسبب عدم
الامتثال كما تقول لمتطلباته القانونيه
فيما يتعلق بحقوق الانسان على خلفيه الحرب
في شمال البلاد
مفاوضات جاريه بين الحكومه الاثيوبيه
والولايات المتحده لاعادته لكن بشكل عام
نعمل على انشاء خيا
رات امريه مستدامه وفتح اسواق جديده في
اوروبا واسيا وافريقيا لدينا البنيه
التحتيه والمجاميع الصناعيه والموارد
والقوه البشريه والنسعى الاستغلالها على
النحو الامثل بدات اثيوبيا الاستفاده من
امتياز اقوى عام 2000 وهوما عزز صناعه
المنسوجات بالبلاد حيث ساهم في جذب علامات
تجاريه عالميه بسبب انخفاض تكاليف العماله
والطاقه ما وفر عشرات الالاف من فرص العمل
وحققه صادرات بلغت العام الماضي نحو ثلاث
256 مليون دولار تقول اثيوبيا انها تتفهم
مخاوف واشنطن المتعلقه بحقوق الانسان وترى
ان القرار لم ياخذ في الاعتبار تاثر سبل
عيشه نحو 200,000 اسره من محدود الدخل
لكنها لا تملك املي في ان تراجع الولايات
المتحده موقفها لا سيما انه يحد من تط
الاثيوبيين في تخليص انفسهم من الفقر حسن
رزاق الجزيره اديس ابابا